the Joe Rogan experience you don't do
drugs you don't drink right you don't
[ __ ] around with anything no yeah that's
like one of the things that we talk like
oh you know when we talked about how I'm
sustainable is that you you have to not
do the certain things that that make it
unsustainable right so I never really
got into drugs I do talk about my book
my first acid trip when I was 13 but
that scared the living [ __ ] out of me
it's to stay away from anything Lucinda
genic and like literally got 13 so I
just stay away from drugs that's a bad
time to do acid it's a very very funny
story but it got to the point where I
just became this this straightedge
hardcore kid I became extremely
religious because I was in this like I
was 13 I was looking up going I'm gonna
be [ __ ] for the rest of my life like
when you're on acid you're like [ __ ]
out there you're just so [ __ ] up and
and when you start thinking like this is
how I'm gonna be forever you're clinging
on to anything that can get you out
right and for me when I grew up as a kid
I'm almost putting me into like Catholic
schools and one of the best thing the
Catholic schools do is indoctrinate kids
on fear and so we you know like you know
I remember going up to the drawing board
like there is like a drawing of what
hell is like guess who's going there
forever people that don't believe you
know and you know when you're young you
start seeing that and and then when you
get into a place of vulnerability where
you're like where I was I was like
scared shitless I was like I'm gonna go
to an insane award when I'm 13 because I
can't get out of this acid hell trip how
long did it last I guess like what seven
eight hours but every second is like a
minute
you know because you cannot sleep you
cannot stop thinking about what you're
in I mean there is like it's like this
exaggerated emotions like the first part
of my acid trip was like I was so funny
I was laughing at everything it was like
the best thing ever did oh my god
everything is so funny I'm just laughing
I'm like in pain because I'm like so
just laughing and everything just
everything's joyous and then like I went
into this upside-down world like
stranger things when I got dropped off
on my friend's how
and everyone went dark and my friends
were my friends 14 he doesn't do drugs
so he was and his mom was coming down
you okay everything's okay
no they knew I was on acid but they're
like you're like I'm like a 80 pound
Japanese kid you know
five foot you know like a little kid
like what the hell is my doing acid for
you know I do talk about like where that
came out but um yeah so like when I was
when I got flipped in that world then
everything was like I saw street fighter
like fireballs from Ryu coming at me
like when I close when I close my eyes
it was very very vibrant and vivid and I
mean it was it's it's a trip for sure so
once you regain sanity you're like
enough of any of this nonsense
yeah yeah once I was like oh my god I'm
back this is this is for real like I
have [ __ ] drugs [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know
like and then I was like I'm straight
edge cuz that's the music I was starting
to get into and then I was like I'm all
about God and Jesus it's gonna save me
you know like he saved me so like as a
kid I was very religious going out and
that you know start exploring more about
the world and and then went more from
this face or faith based concepts of
living through life to you know things
that needed me more he needed to make
sense for me I'm very much more
scientific on like the understanding of
how I want to see things where where did
the change take place when did it take
place uh that would happen to be college
and post where'd you go school UC Santa
Barbara so when you went was great and I
love Santa Barbara god it's like the
hidden gem of California right yeah so
sweet out there yeah
so you just became educated started
learning more about things and it's yeah
I don't know if there was like one spark
that happened it was just kind of like I
just had questions about why things
happen like what what is religion like
what you know you know how things work
in the world how societies are built
did you study theology a little a little
but I don't know if that would be like
the philosophy classes I was taking was
not really the the crux of it sociology
was my major I was Women's Studies and
sociology when I was in college women's
studies yeah well yeah well yeah I have
to say like strangely No Fee that's the
first thing you think about right why
why is a guy in women's studies like try
to understand I mean the reason why I
was in that department is because my
favorite teachers were the ones teaching
those classes so I just was like all
right I'll try this one
and then oh like wow this is a pretty
interesting I'll try another one and and
then I was like well I'll just I'll
finish off the major and uh you know I'd
have to say like the stuff that I
learned in school it's in large part of
how I kind of looked through kind of
like navigate through our life like
sociology I am a sociologist I've want
to study people like why they do certain
things you know like how do i navigate
them in different directions well and
then you've become a purveyor of great
fun like that's essentially what you do
profession you give people great time
yeah your shows of this wild extremely
energetic experience for people and they
leave there's a certain level of
transform ins right I've watched some of
your [ __ ] online and you do these
enormous crowds man and it's so epic and
you see all those people going [ __ ]
crazy and dancing along to your [ __ ] I
mean it's got to be a wild wild feeling
knowing that you're giving this really
positive experiences right thousands and
thousands of people that are just
roaring along to your music yeah Wow ya
know as you say I'm like you know you
know like
yeah no it's because it is exactly what
you're saying and that's why I'm I guess
you could say I'm addicted to that and
because I care so much about that I have
to be sustainable
you know that goes back to what we're
talking about like what do I do as you
do - there's no [ __ ] way you could do
250 shows a year and get [ __ ] up 250
oh yeah because there's a lot you know
in that business especially you know the
business of electronic dance music
there's a lot of people doing Molly
right there's a lot of people doing all
kinds of amphetamines and all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] and you know things like you
do that every night man you're gonna
look like an 80 year old man because
you've literally burned the candle with
a blow torch you've used that Elon Musk
not a flame you know I mean it's but you
know what I always say if whenever I
have the opportunity is that for the
people in my crowds and I had to say
country-by-country they're very
different as far as like what I think if
they're doing drugs or not where are
they do the most drugs um no I don't
think so
I don't but you know it's hard like it's
like I'm just judging right I don't know
like what people are doing out there I
could judge by how interactive they are
that's the best way I can tell right if
they're like yeah that's the worst
that's the worst like subject to play -
it's like literally playing at a
cocktail party when their backs are
turned to you it's the same kind of
thing for me so if they're already high
and they just like lost in their world
like it's no fun for me plus I spend so
much time making like my set so
interactive so engaging and entertaining
like it's bit disrespectful but like you
know some people are gonna do it you're
not gonna be like the debbie downer be
like y'all drugs get the hell out of
here what percentage do you think in
Vegas would leave oh I don't know I
don't know I know you want it I don't
even want to know I don't even want to
know
honestly like we are weeds different
though yeah weeds more like chill you
know like but
if you're so like highs went off your
head where you can't you don't even know
where you are what's going on then like
you just lose the whole experience I
mean a lot of times people like whoa
what happened well I mean what's the
point of you know the experience if you
yeah you're so blitzed out of your head
you don't even know what's going on so
allegedly during the experience they're
having a good time yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]